and my question for mr martin and i'm a
huge fan
and i've been fan for about 10 years now
is
if he could have dinner with three of
his characters from the series
uh which three characters would he
choose and why
very good question i have to say well
certainly tyrion
because he would be witty and charming
and all of that so he would be a very
good choice i think to start with
uh maybe uh maester aemon oh yeah
because he's
wise and knowledgeable and he knows all
these stories about history and
things like that um
the third one i don't know um i could
say
arya but she might misbehave and hit me
with some food
[Laughter]
maybe danny because you know she's
really hot
you know especially if she wore that
corthian gown that would be yeah
i'd like to have dinner with danny
wearing that corthy again
that's what i'm saying i don't know if
the quartean gown made it into the
second season i have a feeling that uh
that
it may not have it's not only uh
fans who have questions for you also um
people who embody the characters stars
of game of thrones have a question
here's emilia clarke who we've been
looking at all night who plays
danny she has a question for you
does danny get the iron throne
that's what i want skin
such a simple question and yet so
complicated and
such an answer i'm going to evade giving
okay
i'm sure you were i'm but you know it
was a reason you have to keep reading
and keep acting she looks so different
without the blonde wig doesn't she
um she's she's actually uh yes people
don't recognize her
no i've interviewed her twice i'm always
like shocked but it's
uh so yeah without the wig so she's not
being known on the streets and all that
which is
you know probably a blessing in in in
many ways uh on the other hand uh poor
jack gleason who is a really
sweet kid who who plays joffrey it's
going yeah i don't know what's going to
happen to that kid
people cursing him on the street you son
of a [ __ ]
yeah i'd like to slap your face
i would i would totally say that to that
and i wouldn't even
i don't i wouldn't even call him i would
just be joffrey as he's always going to
be jaw-free to me
but i mean do you have this planned out
i mean jk rowling has said she always
knew how it was going to end
do you have this planned out i have it
planned out to an extent i mean i
i like to compare it to a to a journey
like if if i set off to drive from
new york to los angeles let us say i
would look at a road map and i would say
okay well this is the road i'm going to
take and
you know i'll drive to chicago the first
night and i'll stay there and
then i'll head south and i'll do that
but i wouldn't necessarily know
you know where i was going to have lunch
the first day or where i might pick up a
hitchhiker or
where there'll be a horrible traffic
accident that'll delay me for six hours
so
there are adventures along the journey
from the details but you know the broad
strokes of the journey you know your
ultimate destination
and you know the main landmarks across
the way well i have to go through
chicago i have to go through kansas city
i have to go through phoenix etc
and i know that i know the ending i know
the fate of the principal characters
uh there's been a lot of characters who
have sort of uh popped up and butted
their way into the story and uh
i'm i'm still sort of making up their
fates on the on the uh
who's the hitchhiker here's the greasy
spoon that's right